يعني رجعنا تقريبا 50 سنه لورا بقدر نقول
يمكن اكثر يعني شويه فرجعنا للبواب وطبعا
ما فيش عوامل امان نهائيا فبتعمل يعني من
قله الامكانيات ومن قله المواد وطبعا بس
نضل على قد البابور ما نرجع اكثر من هيك
يعني
لورا هذا الببور كان مهنه ابوي انا مهندس
تبريد استاذ جامعه خريج المانيا اليوم هذه
المهنه احنا بنساعد الناس بحيث انه الناس
تقوم بواجبات البيت بسمله الطبيع تسخين مي
اي شيء احنا بنساعد
الناس البابور اظ مسخن عليه ميه بطبخ عليه
يعني لمرحله محدوده يعني مش حيستمر ايام
واشهر لان السلر المتوفر ما بكفينا يعني
ايام بس يعني اللي عندي بكفي يوم او يومين
طبعا اضرار الاضرار من البابور يعني
الدخنه والامور هذه والانبعاثات اللي
بتطلع
ما في يعني فيش مجال يعني لتستخدم يعني
مجبرا اخك
بطله الناس كلها كانت تخبز على طنجره
الكهرباء عن طريق القرص طبعا هذا الاساسي
والعضم والكابل فلقيت انقطعت الكهرباء
فاكرنا طنجره عن طريق الفحم بيجي مثلا
بقول لك بدي انا نار بقول له مثلا زي
الفرن فرن كبير اللي هو زي المايكروويف بس
احنا بنسميه فر مادال ما هو كهرباء تحول
ايش تحول نار جديد قديم لانه عندك انت
ازمات ازمه كهرباء وازمه ميه وازمه حطب
حتى كمان ازمه
فحم يعني عندك الحاره كلها بتشتغل على
واحد الجيران اليوم بتساعد بعض كل واحد
بعطي له جاره تشاركوا فيه الناس
اليوم حصلنا على البابور يعني في صديق
اننا في رفح
كنت ادور على غاز يعني مافيش يعني ما جاش
في بال البابور لما لقيت عنده معلق
البابور وقلتله يعني من وين البابور هذا
قال ايام اول ما هاجرنا وجينا في 67 او في
69 شري مش حديث كمان يعني احنا نزوح في
نزوح في لجوء في لجوء ابائنا هاجروا
جلادنا هاجروا وكل واحد روي للي بعده
اليوم هذا ابني حروي لاولاده في المستقبل
كيف هجرنا كمان مره من شمال غزه وجينا على
رفح
اول بوابير صلحنا في 2008 ابوي منت هذه
المهنه يمكن من 50 60 سنه الله يرحمه تمام
وبعده اجا اخوي بعدين انا جيت واليوم احنا
بشتغل في الشغل هذا 2008 الناس انقطع
الوقود رجعوا لايش رجعوا ل البوابير 2014
صارت الازمه رجعوا ل البوابير اليوم 2023
رجعنا للبواب ونصلح البوابير ونظل نصلح
[موسيقى]
بوابير